INCREASINGLY ASSERTIVE CHINA
TAKING A MORE MUSCULAR APPROACH.
HOW SHOULD THE WEST RESPOND?
WE HAVE AN EXPERT ON EAST ASIA
AND U.S. NATIONAL SECURITY AND
ALSO AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS AND
SHE'S JOINING ME NOW FROM
AUSTIN.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
WE HEARD FROM TAIWAN'S
PRESIDENT, BEIJING HAS NEVER
ABANDONED ITS AMBITIONS TOWARDS
TAIWAN.
BEIJING IS REPLACING ITS
COMMITMENT TO A PEACEFUL
RESOLUTION TO AN AGGRESSIVE
POSTURE.
WHY IS CHINA DOING THIS NOW AND
WHAT IS IT TRYING TO GET OUT OF
IT?BIANNA.
HI FROM AUSTIN.
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
OVER THE WEEKEND WHAT WE SAW IS
THAT CHINA SENT A LARGE NUMBER
OF PLANES INTO TAIWAN'S AIR
DEFENSE IDENTIFICATION ZONE.
AN AIR DEFENSE IDENTIFICATION
ZONE IS A SPACE AROUND THE
ISLAND OF TAIWAN THAT EXTENDS
BEYOND NATIONAL AIR SPACE.
NATIONAL AIR SPACE ACTUALLY ONLY
EXTENDS ABOUT 12 MILES FROM
TAIWAN'S COASTLINE.
AND SO A LOT OF COUNTRIES CHOOSE
TO HAVE AN AIR DEFENSE
IDENTIFICATION ZONE WHICH IS
LARGER TO GIVE THE COUNTRY AND
MILITARY TIME TO RESPOND TO
INCOMING FOREIGN AIRCRAFT IF
THEY NEED TO.
AND WHAT WAS CONCERNING ABOUT
THE PLANES THAT CHINA SENT WAS
THE NUMBER.
IT WAS ACTUALLY MORE IN FOUR
DAYS THAN THE ENTIRE PREVIOUS
MONTH BUT ALSO THIS SPECIFIC
TYPE OF PLANES.
THERE WERE PLANES THAT TYPICALLY
DON'T DO THESE KINDS OF FLIGHTS
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST AND THE
TIMING SO THEY'RE PRACTICING
DOING THESE FLIGHTS AT NIGHT.
WHAT THAT SUGGESTS IS THAT CHINA
IS PRACTICING AND TRYING TO GAIN
SOME VERY SPECIFIC MILITARY
ADVANTAGES BY CONDUCTING THESE
TYPES OF OPERATIONS.
AND THERE ARE THREE OR FOUR
THINGS THAT THEY WOULD GET OUT
OF DOING THIS ON THE MILITARY
PART AND THEN THERE'S ALSO SORT
OF POLITICAL SIGNALING LOGIC
HERE.
SO ON THE MILITARY PART, CHINA
IS PROBABLY TESTING TAIWAN'S
REACTION.
THEY'RE SEEING HOW GOOD ARE THEY
AT MONITORING PLANES THAT ARE
COMING INTO THE AIR DEFENSE
IDENTIFICATION ZONE.
HOW QUICK ARE THEY TO RESPOND.
AND WHAT IS THE RESPONSE WHEN
CHINA SENDS DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PLANES AND DIFFERENT
COMBINATIONS OF PLANES.
TESTING TAIWAN'S RESPONSE IS
ONE.
SECOND CHINA IS PRACTICING
COORDINATING ITS OWN AIR FORCES.
CHINA HAD A VERY RAPID MILITARY
BUILDUP.
ITS PILOTS ARE STILL LEARNING
HOW TO DO COMPLEX OPERATIONS AT
INCREASINGLY GREATER DISTANCES
FROM BASIS.
AND SO THEY JUST NEED THE
PRACTICE IN A VERY PRAGMATIC
MILITARY SENSE.
THIRD IS THAT THIS IS REALLY
EXPENSIVE FOR TAIWAN TO RESPOND
TO, BOTH THE FUEL COSTS, HARD ON
THE PILOTS.
REMEMBER, CHINA HAS ABOUT 1,500
FIGHTERS.
TAIWAN HAS ONLY ABOUT 400 AND A
LOT OF THE PLANES ARE OLDER.
THIS REALLY WEARS DOWN AND WAERS
OUT TAIWAN'S ABILITY TO DEFEND
ITSELF.
PUTS A LOT OF PRESSURE ON
TAIWAN.
>> BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN A
VACUUM.
THAT'S WHAT'S CAUSING ALL OF
THIS ALARM.
WE HAVE SEEN THE UNPRECEDENTED
AGGRESSION THAT NO ONE EXPECTED
SO QUICKLY WITH HONG KONG.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT'S TRANSPIRING
DOMESTICALLY WITH XI JINPING
REALLY GOING AFTER PRIVATE
COMPANIES AND ENTERPRISE WITHIN
THE COUNTRY AS WELL.
AND THERE IS THIS SENSE AMONG
EXPERTS THAT HE IS TRYING TO
CAPITALIZE ON HOW THE WEST HAS
BADLY HANDLED AND RESPONDED TO
COVID, GIVING THIS AURA OF
AUTHORITARIANISM BEING ABLE TO
MUSTER MORE STRENGTH AROUND THE
WORLD AND FLEX ITS MUSCLES.
DO YOU THINK THAT THAT'S -- THAT
THAT'S PART OF THIS AT ALL?
OR DO YOU THINK THIS IS ALL JUST
SOMETHING FOR DOMESTIC
CONSUMPTION?
>> I THINK IT IS FOR DOMESTIC
CONSUMPTION BUT I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS IS ABOUT A CHANGING
CHINA'S ROLE AND PLACE IN THE
WORLD.
AND SPECIFICALLY A VISION THAT
XI JINPING HAS OF PUTTING CHINA
AT THE CENTER OF THE WORLD
STAGE.
SO, YES, YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THIS
DID TAKE PLACE OVER PROBABLY THE
CLOSEST EQUIVALENT THAT THE PRC
HAS TO THE FOURTH OF JULY, SO
IT'S A NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
PATRIOTISM, I'VE BEEN IN CHINA
DURING THIS WEEK AND PATRIOTISM
IS ON SORT OF FULL DISPLAY.
IT'S RUNNING VERY HIGH.
THERE'S OFTEN A MILITARY PARADE
WHERE NEW MILITARY HARDWARE IS
DISPLAYED.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THAT DOMESTIC
CONTEXT IS PART OF THIS.
BUT, YEAH, XI JINPING
UNQUESTIONABLY HAS TAKEN CHINA
IN A DIRECTION THAT IS MUCH MORE
REPRESSIVE AT HOME, A CRACKDOWN
ON TECH, BUT ALSO IN TIBET AND
IN GENERAL ON RELIGIOUS AND
ETHNIC MINOR TIS AND CITIZENS
MORE BROADLY WITH THE BUILDUP OF
THIS SURVEILLANCE STATE.
BUT ALONG WITH BEING MORE
REPRESSIVE AT HOME, CHINA HAS
BECOME INCREASINGLY ASSERTIVE
ABROAD.
AND WE SEE THAT AT CHINA'S
PREFERABLY.
WITH HONG KONG AND THE RAMD
SECURITIZATION AND MAKING HONG
KONG INTO A NATIONAL SECURITY
BAST ONFOR THE CCP AS WELL AS
THINGS LIKE THE TERRITORY THAT'S
DISPUTED WITH JAPAN, THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA AND CHINA'S ROAM IN
INTERNATIONAL INSTITUTIONS WHERE
CHINA IS INCREASINGLY TRYING TO
RE-WRITE THE RULES OF GLOBAL
GOVERNANCE TO FAVOR CHINA'S
INTEREST AND TO LEGITIMATE ITS
SYSTEM OF AUTHORITARIAN
GOVERNANCE.
>> YEAH.
IT DOES SEEM TO BE A TEST OF
WESTERN COUNTRIES AS WELL.
THE U.S. POLICY FOR MANY
ADMINISTRATIONS HAS BEEN ONE OF
STRATEGIC AMBIGUITY HERE AND NOT
HAVING SPECIFIC POLICIES AT
LEAST PUBLICLY DISPLAYED IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE U.S. WOULD DO
IF, IN FACT, CHINA DID TAKE OVER
AND INVADE TAIWAN.
I'M WONDERING FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE, IS IT TIME TO
CHANGE THAT POLICY GIVEN THE
ACTIONS THAT WE'VE SEEN AS OF
LATE FROM XI JINPING?
SHOULD WE BE MORE -- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MORE ALLIANCES
OBVIOUSLY, PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPEAKS OF THE THREAT FROM CHINA
REPEATEDLY.
HE KEPT MANY OF THE SAME
POLICIES FROM TRADE ON DOWN AND
THE TARIFFS ARE STILL IN PLACE
AGAINST CHINA, BUT IS THERE MORE
THAT THE U.S. COULD BE DOING
VIS-A-VIS TAIWAN?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS IS NECESSARILY THE TIME TO
REVISE STRATEGIC AMBIGUITY IN
PART BECAUSE TAIWAN HASN'T SKZ
US TO.
THE PEOPLE OF TAIWAN AS WAS
MENTIONED REALLY SHOULD BE THE
ONES WHO DECIDE THEIR OWN FATE
AND THEIR OWN STATUS.
AND THE UNITED STATES HAS ALWAYS
HAD A VERY CLEAR COMMITMENT THAT
WHATEVER TAIWAN'S STATUS IS IT
HAS TO BE RESOLVED PEACEFULLY.
THAT'S NOT AT ALL AMBIGUOUS THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
THE IDEA HERE I THINK THE UNITED
STATES SHOULD PRIORITIZE ACTIONS
BEFORE WORDS.
STRATEGIC AMBIGUITY IS RHETORIC,
IT'S DECLARATORY.
IT'S WHAT WE SAY WE'RE GOING TO
DO IN A HYPOTHETICAL SITUATION
BUT THE REALITY IS THERE'S A LOT
THAT NEEDS TO GO ON ON THE
GROUND TO BUILD UP TY WAUP'S
ABILITY TO DEFEND ITSELF FROM AN
OUTRIGHT INVASION OR MIGHT BE
EVEN A SITUATION LIKE A BLOCK
AID WHERE BEIJING TRIES TO FORCE
TAIWAN'S CAPITULATION WITHOUT
ACTUALLY INVATING BUT BY PUTTING
CHOKE POINTS OR A BLOCK AID
AROUND THE ISLAND TO TRY TO
FORCE IT INTO SUBMISSION.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE UNITED
STATES AND TAIWAN ARE NOT VERY
WELL PREPARED FOR THAT WHOLE
RANGE OF SCENARIOS.
SO, I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
US THINKING ABOUT AND PLANNING
FOR THESE TYPES OF CONTINGENCIES
AND REALLY MAKING SURE THAT THAT
COMMITMENT TO A PEACEFUL PROCESS
IS UPHELD.
YOU'RE RIGHT, XI JINPING STILL
TALKS ABOUT THE NEED FOR
PEACEFUL UNIFICATION.
BUT ME'S ALSO GIVEN SOME SIGNALS
THAT HE MIGHT HAVE A NARROWER
TIMELINE.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR AT THIS POINT
THAT THE PRC'S GOALS AS IT
RELATES TO TAIWAN ARE LONG
STANDING AND REALLY AREN'T
CHANGED.
THAT'S FIRST TO DETER
INDEPENDENCE.
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE BY
TAIWAN AND SECOND TO PURSUE
UNIFICATION.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A LOT
OF DEBATE AND CONCERN AND
ANXIETY ABOUT IS THAT IT USED TO
BE THAT THE TIMEFRAME WAS LONG
AND REALLY INDEFINITE AND BOTH
THE TIMING AND THE TACTICS UNDER
XI JINPING ARE MUCH MORE UP IN
THE AIR.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SEEING THINGS
LIKE THE G7 TALK ABOUT TAIWAN
AND THE NEED FOR PEACE AND
STABILITY IN THE TAIWAN STRAITS
FOR THE FIRST TIME THAT I CAN
THINK OF THE G7 INCLUDING
TAIWAN.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE UK AND
FRANCE DOING FREEDOM OF
NAVIGATION OPERATIONS IN THE
INDO-PACIFIC.
WHY YOU SEE MULTILATERAL
EXERCISES GOING ON AND NEW
DEFENSE SPENDING BILL IN TAIWAN,
THE APPLICATION TO JOIN CTPTT,
RIGHT?
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE A
RESPONSE TO THIS PERCEIVED
ATTEMPT TO CUT O